now yesterday we showed you that morgan
wall and what morgan wallin was up to
last weekend
let's take a look again so there's
morgan at various
bars last weekend in alabama
not social distancing from people he
didn't know
even making out with a couple girls it
didn't really seem like he knew them
before either
this was just days before he was set to
enter the saturday live bubble in order
to perform this weekend
uh yeah well morgan made his way to new
york city
but after these videos went viral over
the past couple of days morgan contacted
by snl
and told sorry you are not coming
here i'm in new york city
in a hotel room i was getting ready for
snl this saturday
and i got a call from the show let me
know that i will no longer be able to
play
and that's because of coveted protocols
which i understand
i'm not positive for code but
my actions this past weekend
were pretty short-sighted and they have
obviously affected
my long-term goals and my dreams
i respect the show's decision
because i know that i put them in
jeopardy and i
i don't take ownership for this
i'd like to apologize to snl to my fans
to my team for bringing me these
opportunities
and i let them down and on a more
personal note
i think i have some growing up to do
um you know i think i've lost myself a
little bit
i i've tried to find joy in the wrong
places and
i don't know it's left me with less joy
so i'm gonna go try to work on that
i'm gonna uh take a step back from the
spotlight for a little while
and go work on myself um
i wish i could have made country music
and my fans proud
this saturday but i respect the decision
once again
and and lauren michaels actually gave me
a lot of encouragement
by letting me know that we'll find
another time to make this up
so that means a lot to me thank you for
that
yeah tsa smart decision uh l says he
obviously needs to mature
ashley's just not positive for covet
positive for the clap it got kicked off
snl roughly
i do not feel sorry for him bored by
noises it's the right thing to do
morgan doesn't even care doesn't look
like he cares
uh yeah she'll says good job snl
it's tough we talked about this
yesterday and i was you know that you
have to you have to tell them that he's
not allowed on set
the amount of precautions that snl has
gone through to even get the show on the
air are astronomical
they're paying audience members as if
they're staffed just to have people in
the building
you cannot go and do this and and the
i'll be honest with you
i didn't know who really morgan was
before any of this happened but i will
say this that snl over the years
has featured musical artists that i had
no idea who they were and then i became
a giant fan
of them after they performed snl is this
incredible platform
where somebody who has not yet broken
into cross-platform status
can go on there and it is really
life-changing and you can
see that in him where he's not
disappointed in himself that you can
this is a guy who's
really disappointed because he looks
like he blew
a huge shot and and i don't know what
other choice snl had i hope they bring
him back on but i think that they did
the right thing
i also see this is an opportunity for
him to write his next song and i think
the title should be
young dumb because it's exactly what he
was he was young and he was stupid and i
think he's
i'm glad the show made this decision i i
couldn't agree more it's like you can't
have everybody else's following the
rules
and then you just think that you could
go do whatever you want and put it on
video i love this about this generation
not only do you do dumb stuff but you've
always got to have a camera to capture
it
um and this is a lesson for him it's
like you know this year i've talked to a
lot of doctors and
all these specialists and psychiatrists
and one group that i've talked to been
hurting the most over the last few
months
are artists because in one week their
entire schedule for 2020
got deleted no concerts nothing and this
is how people live that's how they make
their their livelihood
and so you're right snl has always been
a great platform for
all artists unknown and very popular and
he
messed up in this tie he messed up an
opportunity where you know you're not
doing all those concerts you're not
going on that tour
and you had this great opportunity and
you messed it up so you could make out
with some random strangers they're
talking about
the streams the downloads you could have
you introduce yourself to a whole new
fan base
and i think that he knows that that's
why i think it's such a smart idea for
snl
to say sorry you can't maybe later on i
think i'm sure his team has come down
hard on him like
you can't live this rock star lifestyle
besides like
we're in a pandemic right now it was an
opportunity that a lot of artists i talk
to the host of boots and hearts
they have to take everything virtual
there are a lot of country music artists
who would have
killed for that opportunity and you got
it morgan
and you blew it so you could make out
with girls whose first name you
probably don't even remember so i think
he learned his lesson but again write a
song about it young and dumb